the war on Cops is getting worse
unfortunately so last year saw a
disturbing increase in police getting
killed in the line of duty
331 officers were shot with 64 of them
losing their lives that's roughly a 21
increase over the average from 2010 to
2020. the police Union has a theory on
what's behind it
we have a culture of lawlessness that
has gripped this country it's been
fueled by an open border Rogue DA's
activist judges a revolving door
criminal justice system and generally a
society that tells people you're no
longer accountable for your own actions
but President Biden has an idea on how
to help the police
we have to retrain cops as to why should
they always shoot for with deadly force
the fact is if you need to use your
weapon you don't have to do that and
look to call a Fresh Approach to recruit
and how we recruit how we hire how we
train how we promote and how we retained
retained and for law enforcement and
while police officers get demoralized in
departments deal with recruitment
struggles this isn't helping the LAPD
Banning A Thin Blue Line flag from one
of its stations following a complaint
from someone who thought it represents
racist bigoted views
um Greg any thoughts on what Biden said
today on this theory of just shoot them
in the legs yeah I don't I don't think
he knows what he's saying remember I
mean
I don't know it's sad because we're
still recuperating from a spasm of
anti-cop hatred from four years ago
three years ago we're still not back to
normal there's been a delay a lag
between what we knew was wrong and what
what people are doing about it I mean we
still have to have a debate over no cash
bail right he still is bad-mouthing cops
just like he bad mouth the you know the
the the immigration the Border agents
media approved an elevated anti-police
sentiment to such a degree that fighting
crime has been perceived as racist that
even by by supporting the police that's
somehow racist I don't know if we're
ever going to get back to normal after
this I think that what we're probably
going to be seeing is an evolution
towards private police for those who can
afford it and everyone else gets a
gutted bear police force in the inner
city it'll be like first class and Coach
it'll be like reserve seats in general
admission uh or private and worse it'll
be like private and public bathrooms
because the fact is the people that are
pushing a lot of this stuff they're
wealthy Democrats they don't have to
worry about their safety they don't
their policies and their personal
consequences never meet so I have I have
a feeling that this is going in a weird
Direction where we're going to have just
two separate police forces well they
the trajectory of all of this is not
good judge and it continues but how do
you think cops across the country will
react to What President Biden said it
further adds to their to the morale
problem the the fact that they've been
denigrated uh defunded uh you know
demoralized I mean the cops now know the
statistic I mean the big statistic this
year is that 2022 saw a disturbing
increase in law enforcement fatalities
64 in 2022 which is something like 21
over the the average of 53 over the last
decade so they know they're being shot
at and killed they're being ambushed
they're being bad mouth and this does
nothing and that's why they're leaving
the force many of them before they're
even eligible for retirement right but I
want to talk about this LAPD Chief
Michael Moore Chief Moore you're a wuss
okay you're a wuss okay I got the word
right this time I would have gone
tougher but I can the truth is you
represent the people in law enforcement
and you agree because one person
complained that you're going to take the
side of these cop hating the people who
hate law enforcement you're going to
buckle to the leftist apologist and
those people who hate Law and Order
shame on you you ought to get the hell
out of there I know you want to be the
chief police the chief of police but you
work for communist mayor bass is a mayor
who's well known for being tied to and
supporting Top members of the Communist
Party of the United States they don't
care about Law and Order they only care
about Anarchy and he is just supporting
it that's why the union is wild over
this Joey you talked to somebody at the
LAPD today yeah first of all you don't
surrender that which is sacred only
cowards do that and if this if this Thin
Blue Line symbol is sacred to those who
lose brothers and sisters on the police
force you are not being a leader by
surrendering that because you believe
somebody has co-opted it you fight back
you take control of it you use it
appropriately and you out talk the bad
talkers you are louder than they are
with this symbol that is sacred to you I
want to know who who complains about
this it's not the single mom who's
working three jobs and comes into the
police force or comes into the precinct
to argue against the parking ticket she
can't afford it's not the dad that comes
in to get his Rowdy son out of jail that
pays taxes and abides by the law no
matter what color creed they are the
people that complain about this
according to people that work there are
skilled anti-police activists who
understand the complaint system and knew
exactly what to do to include filing
this complaint from my understanding
from my friend that works to LAPD filing
this complaint at the same Precinct that
officer Arroyos worked out of on the one
year anniversary of him being murdered
hunted down and murdered by a gang they
are sending a message and this police
chief is just accepting it Geraldo well
first of all I agree with what Greg said
about the George Floyd hangover I think
that Society really is still still
suffering from what happened in
Minneapolis and and what happened as a
result of it and then the extremes that
it went to and the Damage that was done
and the Schism that was uh that was
created and it is very sad to me to
follow up on what Joey was saying it is
very sad to me that this wonderful
symbol of the of The Thin Blue Line has
been co-opted by some people who are
racist then bigoted but I think the only
way you fight that is to take it back
fight it back grab it back take back
that uh the fly it on your front lawn I
wear the the pin I celebrate the
relationship with cops they are The Thin
Blue Line Between Anarchy and
civilization that sounds old-fashioned
sometimes but it is still true what
would world the world be what would
America be what would this city or your
city will your town be without a cop a
cop that you could trust and call on
your kid is choking or uh you know
someone's been shot or the store's been
stuck up or this or that who do you call
you call the cop you call the cop say
you prayers you called the cop I think
that it's really uh it is it's
infuriating and and that I just say so
simple thank you for your service
thank you for yourself Noble and
honorable position and we need them hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now